la démocratie n'a pas de prix mais elle
a un coût et
euh le les quand il il est absolument
anormal que plus de la moitié des maires
de France perdent de l'argent en
devenant maire parce que c'est la
réalité beaucoup cumulent avec un job
hein notamment dans les petites commune
euh qui reprente le tissu euh
majoritaire des communes de France et
l'indemnité elle est euh de inférieur au
SMIC nettement inférieur au SMIC hein et
et c'est pas normal et et ça on peut le
regarder en face c'estd que beaucoup de
patrioti compris de ceux qui galèrent
d'abord pens que les ma gagnent beaucoup
plus sont très surpris du montant de
l'adimité notamment dans les petites
communes
et c'est complètement marginal en terme
de dépenses et aujourd'hui il faudrait
qu'un maire qui a une fonction exécutive
une responsabilité civile politique et
pénale et la CAPAC et un revenu de au
moins de cadres moyens quoi enfin ne
soit pas perdant parce que ça contribue
à dévaloriser cette fonction qui est
pourtant la plus belle de la République
française
y